[Music]
we're really white
so don't fuck your mother
[Music]
we wasted our lives to this thing
fuckin size
[Music]
master we got your message about the
impending danger yeah something about a
great evil coming
I sense a terrible force that is
consuming our youth and threatening to
destroy the Ninja Turtles franchise that
is not radical
I sense Megan Fox's April Oh dick ugly
CGI roadkill and all of it being
produced by Michael Bay isn't that the
man so insecure about masculinity he can
transformers testicles the same master
what we do to stop this bullshit first
you must review the movie well done
that's kind of given second you must
find the thoughts of the Ninja Turtles
and remind the world of it it's hard at
the Ninja Turtles where do we begin
start with the basics try rescuing April
O'Neil what she's making it do you see
her right in front of you no then she's
been kidnapped go my sons
find the heart of the franchise and rip
this turtle to a new one
[Music]
it's just mayor does the city seem a
little more animated just as soon you
see everything as a cartoon
come on start the review when we say
they the film starts with their origin
story which i think is paying homage to
the graphic novel but it's kind of
pointless seeing how they're just gonna
explain it again a few scenes later you
are extraordinary my sons but your
training is not yet complete I hope that
VHS tape was Ninja Turtles 3 you are
going to be responsible for amazing
things but they have been in the world
inspired by an overly violent perv like
Frank Miller to a different world
Michael Bay and at the center is Megan
Fox hey you said deaminating agents
those are used in genetic research look
I'm wearing yellow so I'm April now now
the Foxes credit she's really not that
bad yeah April is known for always being
saved but in this film it really only
happens once at the end and even then
she still manages to give the finishing
blow that pretty much never happens
still hey it doesn't help that the
character's likable energy and perkiness
takes a backseat to being dull as a pet
rock hi guys April O'Neil from Channel 6
News and I am here in beautiful New York
City on the first day of spring and you
know what that means
yeah even as the light news stories go
would you really watch her she looks as
disinterested as kids doing a homework
assignment maybe she just needs a
different outfit like the giant cleavage
wrapped in banana peel look no he's so
Michael Bay's nose why do you have this
no reason though give Michael Bay's 13
year old brain credit he did find a way
to actually somehow get her on a
trampoline I want you to visualize a
sexy seagull picture you're leaving the
cold north and you're flying I can just
see him now saying no no it's supposed
to be shot in slo-mo and in extreme
close-ups God it's like this director
sees women as people or something
my guy Stan he'll tell you anything else
you need to know okay she get the tip
from Chef Ramsay that something shady is
going down that night at the docks and
she snooped in to see what it is
yeah wave those guns with light
surrounds nobody will ever notice the
secretive foot clan of course they're
stopped by our unseen heroes as April
notices that they left a calling card
because ninja leave no trace I'm
freaking out I just saw a Foot Clan
attack
oh hi roommate who literally has no
purpose in this movie at all admit it
you forgot she was even in this film
didn't you I was riding my bike by the
docks it was night it's dark already and
there are Foot Clan soldiers everywhere
and then out of nowhere there was this
guy fighting back and for now the dark
can an awesome sound showered cowabunga
as they hit the ground from the field
awaits the heroes rescued the flower cuz
they possess total power no it's in the
past let it go do you party early power
to you party at elite power we need a
lead for tonight who's got it major
redevelopments proposed for lower
Manhattan now hey I got one well the
focus Whoopi Goldberg in this movie I
witness an attempted Foot Clan robbery
at the docks in Brooklyn last night ah
Christ what's today bring your daughter
to work day
I'm gonna assume that you would not come
up here and tell us this fantastic story
without some tangible proof why is she
rolling her eyes like that did she not
want proof of her story maybe she just
doesn't like the folder she's keeping it
in brown oh that's so like her it makes
no sense
hey wait did my voice just come out of
your mouth yeah that was weird
that proof isn't enough but that doesn't
stop the shredder from warming up by
breaking the hands of the Foot Clan with
his chin
I guess people can do that now we
couldn't have anticipated the vigilante
showing up to the dogs
boy was for no Kuni no stars at all are
we speaking Japanese or English we keep
going back and forth I don't believe in
fairy tales
damn it's now you've got me doing it
it's like vine once you see someone do
it you wanna start doing it yourself the
Foot Clan lures the Turtles out by
holding people hostage in a green subway
because for some reason subways and
movies always have to be green you know
you're out there hostages don't make me
explain why everyone is hiding their
identity behind a mask except me oh I'm
hoping they put my face on assassins
weekly patrols of course saved the day
and April is the only one who somehow
notices them and follows damn it's so
close the design of the turtles aren't
that bad they have different articles of
clothing that not only match their
character but also help us to tell them
apart easier but Jesus Christ what did
they do to their faces they just look
ugly
it's like if The Annoying Orange was an
annoying avocado or if slippy frog got
Botox injections and then got herpes or
if the Finding Nemo turtle got jaundice
or if that troll from Lord of the Rings
joined a street gang bottom line they
don't look very good like a radioactive
smurf that got caught in an oyster you
got too greedy I know do not say a word
about this to anyone if you do we will
find you April O'Neil
oh they know her name she's on the news
and speaking of April it looks like we
found it unless your friends arrived
your final news no right if we save her
we're sure to get to the heart of the
Ninja Turtles we just need a plan
wait a minute our hourglass is switched
months things have been going on around
here so what we gonna do
well I wired one of my calculators into
this super molecular discombobulating
device it seems amazingly implausible
but what's next our Dule Hill by oh I
just rearranged his molecules using the
bio energy emanating from this retro
animator integrator science babble
science babble science babbling yeah
this is amazing we can trace the way yes
actually let's never use it comment on
it or ever reference it again that works
too get out fine I get tired you think
about it the whole time of course these
guys know as much about tying knots as
ALJ's the why the hell to do anything
and it's a great story
right behind operation is literally
brain behind operations villains tried
to take over the world with alien
technology when they could just make a
fortune selling it
vehicles roam the city during the day
and nobody seems to care
Daryl's tried to stay here even though
they are constantly on
in newspapers news reporter wears a
yellow jumpsuit during every master I
don't think we're looking in the right
place there's something very silly about
this very well defeating the Foot Clan I
hear they're trying to blow up the city
damn and that's not bad the foot the big
bar of the trails identity it's my son's
you can do it you can do it alright
let's go kick some foot that
surprisingly not redundant
there's something very familiar about
this we do not get off while losing
pixelated someone oh come on we have a
job to do so strangely enough April and
the turtles had a connection before as
her home movies reveal not only did she
used to be mara Wilson but she also saw
the turtles grow up in her father's lab
she even gave them their love of pizza
so this part is gonna piss off the
purest of turtle fans so while we talk
about I'm gonna put something up to
distract you so that you can get more
angry about that rather than what we're
saying I kind of like that change yeah
you do don't get me wrong the stars must
have all had to been aligned for them to
meet up like that again but it is kind
of clever giving them a connection early
on it almost makes up for the fact that
they have so little connection beyond
that personally I don't think it was
that bad edition but that doesn't help
prove her case when the like a fucking
dumbass she tries to tell her boss the
truth the turtles are the vigilantes
there are four six-foot talking Turtles
walking around New York City and no one
has seen them but you that's what I'm
telling you okay get out well what the
hell do you think would happen they give
you the pole sir for being a fucking
psychopath well if they did they'd also
give it to Will Arnett as Vernon as he
agrees to help her after being told the
whole story but that could be because
she's the only one who will listen to
his tale stand up you know honey when
you get a coffee it's just like coffee
and then they put old froth on it's kind
of nice foam froth you get the point
it's just it's nice it tastes good it's
candy they look at you and they see wow
there's a nice there's the hell's he
talking about candy the point is
I think that come on it's a Nickelodeon
movie you think I'm gonna use my a
material so they're aliens stupid
reptiles a momentary pause for people
groaning at that piece-of-shit joke okay
that'll do heroes in the half-shell okay
get out
April goes to see Eric Sachs Eric ball
sacks well done played by William
Fichtner who helped her father with his
experiments when he was still alive
April's arrived early this year I was
gonna say April came early this year but
Bay has a bit of a pervy audience I have
other jumps though I used to live on
Fifth Avenue get it Saks and fifth
hahaha I kill me and I might kill you
we'll just have to wait and see well
before you think about that the screen
is slowing everything down anyway that's
your biggest question there's a guy on
fucking fire over there why they hire
these people
[Music]
ah I can't it's dragging me away I'm
swimming through shit right now
something you'll notice is that there's
more attention given to sacks in this
movie than there is the shredder and
that's because sacks was originally
supposed to be the shredder it was
changed because so many people gave them
shit
April the mutagen possesses powers
beyond our wildest hopes Fichtner would
have been so much better yeah it's
totally different but he would have been
great for the part he's weird he's
creepy he's got a strange sick charm to
him yeah he's not Japanese but neither
was Uncle Phil if we can have a cartoon
where April's a teenager with no one
going fucking nuts
why can't we have a movie where this guy
is the shredder instead we get this dull
hunk of wood who could just as easily
been replaced with a scarecrow who
speaks Japanese sometimes futher than
Nepal Mugen Danny nutty oh my what
taking with 10 years to do City love the
hours so cosa so the turtles abduct
April 1st which is really back where is
when do you think about it I mean come
on this doesn't help Mikey's creeper
talk at all but we can still have the
dull conversation girlfriends totally
the hogo-sha it would be fair he was
still pretty creepy in the original
where she meets splinter and we learned
more about their backstory
your father had discovered the truth
behind the man he was working for he set
fire to the lab his last breath was
taken trying to destroy a shredders plan
so he accidentally set himself on fire
what kind of scientist is this
he creates mutant turtles but can't
light a match without burning alive
maybe he's the guy in Ninja Turtles the
NES game even his daughter got out of
there fine and she's obviously like half
his age look Shiva managed to save the
turtles sort of she lays them in the
street I'm sure the cars will take good
care of them we wandered the sewers
until I found this place they start to
mutate over the years and learn about
humanity by peeking out at Times Square
not a bad idea
but then we get the dumbest edition of
all
[Music]
and then I found a way who the dick
sausage masters ninjitsu from a fucking
book it's not even a good book look at
it
they're like drawings from Game & Watch
you're not supposed to just be good
they're supposed to be amazing and then
they got that from this where's the
chapter saying how to dodge bullets
where's the chapter saying how to jump
off cliffs where's the chapter that
teaches you how to read Japanese yeah
the book is in Japanese how did they
even read this if they're English
speaking Turtles the Times Square just
have Japanese lessons on the hour every
hour
hey the Japanese word for good afternoon
is konichiwa if you're a total out there
I hope you got that nobody questions no
shredder finds them and blows up their
hideout injuring most of them would've
made sense to hide in their shells for
that nah they're just there to put
advertisements on oh wait we don't need
that they just say naturally on their
own and if you thirsty
I got a secret stash Orange Crush behind
the fridge why would that need to be
secret maybe the taste is so good that
it has to be kept a secret go by crush
now oh look a shred former he's mixing
the ancient art of ninjitsu with
high-tech robotic bullshit very Japanese
the more I think about it shredder
all these years I've been trying to
recreate the mutagen and you you just
handed it to me will not lay a hand we
met
we're talking like we have this long
history but the British are this is the
first time we've ever seen each other oh
come on you're not even lucky to be
while I fight
that's just rude shredder beats up
splitter and captures three the turtles
leaving unconscious Rafael behind
where's the fourth he's dead
destroy this place you know that not
really as much destroyed this place as
much as create a bit of a fixer-upper I
mean come on three people survived that
destroyed this place okay looks like
you're punching your munchkin jaw as in
jerking off you know what to me okay we
only got one more bomb to defuse it up
that time Oh bad noise you know it is
only water yeah people can use a good
swim yeah it's not like we're like
anybody important I'm right master this
isn't working I feel like we're not any
closer to the heart of the Turtles hmm
go straight for it don't defeat the
shredder if that doesn't lead to the
heart of the Turtles nothing and
remember you have my support she loves
our work
30-something nerdy critics will return
after these messages
[Music]
thank you you must save your brothers so
splitter seems to be on his deathbed
well what's the best thing to do leave
him behind and go kick some ass come on
guys
babysitter calm I'm a hard guy to
impress and we were gonna use rabbits
can you imagine that actually I would
totally watch that for what I'll show
you cry show them in a few hours
shredder is going to unleash all that
stuff over the whole city huh that was
random the guy has to die just so you
can have visual for your speech yeah
that was a member of the Foot Clan I
wouldn't be happy that my 401k was going
to chin death and being killed for a
PowerPoint presentation I'm gonna save
everyone with the antidote that is made
from the mutagen that is oozing through
your blood and I'm gonna be rich like
stupid rich yep that's the whole reason
for this folks so an already rich man
can be a stupid rich man you know
putting stupid in front of your
motivation surprisingly doesn't make it
any less stupid
maybe we emphasize even more how stupid
rich he'll be oh you mean like making a
Smurfs 3 stupid rich or he'll be LJN
stupid rich I hope he is the dress black
or blue stupid rich where he'll be
Michael Bay stupid rich close to home
okay
but to be fair makes about as much sense
as this shredder all right so what's the
grand plan again well we steal things
yeah that's as far as I got
look you got a cool arcade but I'm not
gonna put my life on the line for that
no it's all good we're going to take
over the city with ninjitsu uh you do
know they have guns out there right we
have ninjutsu but they have gone
seriously you have nunchucks swords axes
don't you think a few firearms would
step things up a bit you don't
understand we're hunting Turtles ah
you've been smoking why are we still
listening to this this is your family
and you're the drunk uncle who beats up
the rodent section at Petsmart what glad
is strai dead witness I got an idea
but rafen the gang break in fighting off
only four guards to get inside what to
keep killing off men to make more
speeches well remember he's not stupid
rich yet so maybe he couldn't afford
them thus he fights the shredder getting
his ass handed to him but he just walks
away
there's not even any guards left you're
literally leaving them open to being
rescued apologies will domination is
wanting but I am NOT going to miss an
episode of better console April breaks
them out by giving them an adrenaline
overload literally transforming them
into Michael Bay's core audience they
steal a truck from the foot by heat oh
come on are you a super secret army or
not and they have what's honestly a
pretty fun chase down a hill it's stupid
but it's stupid in all the right ways
even that has some shit that doesn't
make sense
like I'm still not sure how the hell a
bow can flip an entire car maybe it's a
stupid bow-wow that's unlike a faith
film showing that looking at a woman's
ass can be a bad thing
we gotta get a fool out of there what
about the unfunny wormy guy leave him we
loved him this incredibly flamboyant
dance club he drank all the mutagen why
does that make his clothes grow to where
you can just go out like a little bitch
if there's story here you know this is
epic as I remember it yeah and I think
that rappers lyrics are a little precise
to the situation this guy's you look at
absurd looking kind of angry also like a
nerd this freestyle is real yo I didn't
rehearse it time for the chorus I'm done
with the first pitch hey guys working
with us to ancient Japan with our
time-traveling stick yeah you're missing
out man gonna fight a British guy with a
birdcage master I don't get it what are
we doing wrong
don't give up just yet my son's victory
is upon you how the hell are you doing
that through the art of ninjitsu I'm
pretty sure that's not how that works
shut up
you must try at least one more round
okay and what would that be
you must form right
what put on some Turtle costumes get in
front of a crowd something's not right
here
the turtles get to the tower to defeat
the shredder leading to funny enough
probably the best scene in the movie MC
Mikey MC this could be their final
mission and yet they don't take time for
this random bit of silliness it's
everything that's great about the
turtles in only a couple of seconds how
can you not get sucked in
[Music]
the turtles rushed to the roof and have
their final big battle with the shredder
oh is that what this is there's so much
CGI I thought I was watching somebody
playing Soul Calibur
yeah we got a 10-10 that's right a 10-10
for giant turtles fighting a mecca metal
samurai by god it's been a few days
[Music]
cowabunga oh I think you could have made
them work in McKee than that
how about yippie Cal motherfucking hasta
your worst nightmare Bunga biatch they
stopped the machine and save April just
in time for her to finally not shredder
on his ass well I got a few seconds let
me think about to where I went wrong oh
yeah they nursed splinter back to health
April's still out of a job and they're
right off in their own turtle van again
adapting to the art of invisibility but
wait we just watched a Michael Bay
production and there wasn't one giant
fireball explosion the whole thing ah
there it is
movie fell vacant for a second my bad
and that is how Michael Bay sucked the
dignity out of the Ninja Turtles hey
buddy ready to do this let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh mommy can i fuck shit - this isn't
the heart of turtles pulling up yours
I don't think we're getting any closer
to what we're looking for here alright
alright alright look
perhaps if you made little plastic
versions of yourself
you mean like action figures oh yeah
actually a lot like an action figures I
don't see her I see what you're trying
to do you're trying to make this into
toys yeah you're trying to sell us
before you have any kind of story or
characters or anything yeah that's what
the original Turtles did
yeah don't you remember the toy brand
was made first before the show in fact
they had to break the episodes of round
the toys as opposed to the toys around
the episodes even the graphic novel was
a satire of comic books at the time it
was ever meant to be taken that
seriously but we took it that seriously
so wait was the heart of the Ninja
Turtles all this time just to sell toys
yeah so if you could just get out with
removing all possible choking hazards we
want turtles we want the biggest parts
of our childhood was just a giant
commercial time
[Music]
maybe that's what it was meant to be but
not how it turned out huh
look at all the ideas that have lasted
over the years like Batman and Superman
there's so many different versions
because the ideas struck a chord with
people do you think Ninja Turtles will
do the same it already is actually
you're right there's so many variations
of it it's like Alice in Wonderland or
Christmas Carol everybody has their own
interpretation of it maybe that's the
best way to look at this morning it's
stupid and kind of manipulative but it's
not the final word in the franchise it's
just another version there'll be tons of
different varieties to come in the
future
all of them with silly over-the-top
moments but that's part of what we loved
about them in the first place just say
the title Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
it's a goofy idea and always will be
some versions get more wrong than others
but that's part of the fun too
comparing them April can be a grown
woman or a 15 year old girl or a 15 year
old girl but they're always adding
something new while trying to stay true
to what was so crazy about the original
it's not the untouched perfection that
makes it last it's the constant changing
interpretation of other artists
[Music]
so what do you think Marik think the
Michael Bay version is still the worst
one
[Music]
probably not but even if it was it's all
part of the experience of growing yeah -
Charles is going through a lot of
changes some good some bad and that's
what makes it last forever
[Music]
but just to be clear this movie is there
oh yeah yeah
Oh fuckin sucks for you but like I mean
really hard yeah it just it sucks I'm
talking high again fucking day again so
fucking horrible why'd you make me do
[Music]
[Applause]
this rats made it up on the spot quick
like a ninja splitter time real time I
know how to flow just like a turtle
named Michelangelo this guy he's on the
alert cap in a goatee tie with a t-shirt
this guy's you looking absurd looking
kind of angry also like a nerd this
freestyles real yo I didn't rehearse it
time for the chorus I'm done with the
first bitch
stupid bitch
hi guys dog walker here giving you an
update on two Khan's there coming up
this month in April and they are both
Midwest cons which is nice surprisingly
I don't go to that many Midwest cons but
this time I'm going to too in the exact
same month the first one is Midwest
Media Expo and that is in Detroit and is
from April 10th to the 12th and it's not
just me coming it's my brother it's
Malcolm
it's Tamara and a lot of chalice and
people are gonna be there uh Brad Jones
is gonna be there Lewis love Fox
wouldn't be there Lizzie Ellis is gonna
be there the people from shark jumpy are
gonna be there and it's there's a lot of
people honestly I'd have to go look at
the list just there's go to the website
here's the link you can check it out for
yourself there's a lot of people going
there from channel awesome we have our
own section and the guests area on the
site it's just like guess get kiss and
then she'll awesome they take up the
other half of the guests so go say hi to
us we love to chat with you um and then
I also have believe it or not c2e2
which is a really huge con in Chicago
like I said don't do that made Chicago
con strangely enough so it's good to be
at this one this is like a gigantic one
there's good news bad news the bad news
is I'm technically not there as a guess
I'm there as you know I bought a table
and you know people can come up and say
hi to me so forth so I'm not doing a
panels however because it's a desk you
can come up you could talk to me
personally and you can get merchandise
and stuff you don't have to just sit in
a chair and have your hand up for a Q&A
you can just come right up to me and ask
me whatever you want
and yeah I'd love to see you guys come
out there so whether it's - whether it's
coming to Detroit or Chicago both are
gonna be wonderful
oh also a c2e2 I'm also gonna have Rob
and Malcolm and - amber gonna be there
as well and they love fans and they love
company and they would love to say hi to
all you guys so if you can drop on by
that'd be wonderful please go ahead to
check us out the c2e2 one is at the end
of April and here's the address for that
it it's a big con so it'll be pretty
easy to find but there's the address
anyway and I'm just rambling on now so
if you'd like to come and say hi go
ahead and do so and hopefully we'll see
you there
take care